hey everyone and welcome to the second
part of this series um this is the
battery saving tips series and this
particular tip works very well in
windows vista
i'm going to show you a little software
part after this actual uh camera review
so the second tip in this tutorial is
going to be to disable arrow uh windows
vista arrow you probably already know
this is what um it's basically the you
know the flip 3d and the cool little
fades and the task things popping in in
windows vista um this actually does work
your gpu quite hard not your cpu but
your gpu your graphic your graphics
processing unit so
with a laptop um obviously this laptop
the 17 inch model has a built-in
graphics card and nvidia geforce with
512 megs of built-in ram
it's it's going to heat up and it's got
it's going to use a lot more battery
than normally than a normal laptop would
that doesn't have a built-in um graphics
graphics card or maybe just has
integrated graphics
so disabling windows aero will save you
a lot of battery life quite a bit
actually
if you're say you're on an airplane and
you really want max battery and you're
not too concerned maybe you're just
checking your offline gmail like i
showed you how in a tutorial or um
maybe you're just watching a movie or
listening to some music so i don't
really need windows arrow so go ahead
and check out this software view on how
to disable windows xero
right here's the software part guys
first of all you're going to right click
on your desktop anywhere in windows
vista and hit the personalize button you
may have seen before in other you know
youtube tutorials youtube videos on how
to speed up windows well not only will
this speed it up and make operations
faster but this will also give you quite
a long battery life so go to windows
color and appearance
and open classic appearance properties
for more color options
so it's going to open this window
you'll see here this says windows arrow
color scheme
now what i'm going to do is it was just
a basic it didn't change the preview i'm
not sure why the aero preview was weird
but you can see like the transparent
taskbar and the cool little fade things
so under appearance just take windows
standard which will bring you way back
to windows 98 or just go to classic or
vista basic or something and you can
enjoy that too now i'm going to cancel
because i'm plugged in right now but uh
that's the easy way to fine tune your
color and style of windows now if you
don't want to go the drastic way and
disable arrow completely what you can do
is just to disable transparency by
unchecking that right there and as you
can see if i go over my rocket dock you
can't see it in the background
so that is a quicker and less intensive
way to
speed up your computer and run with way
way longer battery life so don't be
fooled disabling arrow will save you
quite a bit of battery life when you're
not exactly using all the graphics and
having a real desktop experience
so um
thanks for watching guys that was my
tutorial on how to that was my second
part in the video tutorial series on how
to speed up windows on not on how to
speed up windows now this is the second
part of the video tutorial series on how
to
save battery life in windows vista so
thanks for watching and i'll keep the
videos coming peace